welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name
is hisham azuz today
i'm joined by chris bennett who is a
management consultant within
evolution recruitment solutions he's
worked for evolution
for nearly five years has worked in
recruitment for nearly seven
and for the last three years has solely
focused on
the nordics tech market and manages
a small team of five chris
thank you for joining me how you doing
i'm good i'm good excited to unpack
your journey so far and
where i always like to to start on this
podcast is how chris bennett entered the
world of
recruitment let's start there because i
know when we spoke before this you
actually told me
you love recruitment so yeah yeah let's
start there
still still love it how did you how did
you enter the world of recruitment
well i went to university
um i don't know how deep you wanted to
go but went to university
wanting to go into the army as an
officer realized i didn't want to get
shot
at so i came out of university with a
physical geography degree
and um just focusing on glaciers and
there's not too many glaciers knocking
about nowadays
so my um a good friend of mine i went to
university with ranger saying hiring at
his place he was a recruitment company
warrington
went for it's like a big like there's 15
of us banya
assessment center yeah assessment center
i was most unaddressed out of everyone
but they seemed to like me um
and yeah yeah that's that's that's how i
got into it really
what was your perception of recruitment
at that point how was it sold to you
well i hadn't got a clue what it was
yeah all i know was for like the three
months leading up to it
i kept applying for jobs and
they were with recruitment companies my
father didn't relax
so i haven't got a clue about it to be
honest um
all i know that yeah my friend was doing
okay
he was earning a bit of money so yeah i
didn't really know much about it
[Laughter]
so so at that point in your life then
was it just very much
done you need i needed a job recognized
i don't do the army i know that
you did a bit of the army cadet stuff
while she was at uni or whatever so
like it was a real light right i need to
get a job i need to just crack on
basically
yeah that was it really um
yeah i was i wasn't doing anything at
the time i would have done anything
and then fortunately enough my friend
rang me and said
do you want to get into this and then
i've not looked back since two hours
okay so just for contacts with people so
who worked at that first company was it
for two years
yeah yeah so just short of two years
okay just short two years and it's all
you just told me before this has always
been contract recruitment
yeah so just short of two years and then
for the last
pretty much nearly six now no five years
sorry
it's you've been an evolution yeah yeah
so
the first company i was at um what did
they recruit in
mainly oil and gas okay um and
you go into kind of i went into that job
and it was mainly
like pure recruitment not really the
sales part of it
so i had a kind of a view on what
recruitment was which
massively changed when i joined what
would you what do you mean pure
recruitment what you just do
yeah delivery finding candidates you
spend your whole day finding condoms
you weren't really qualifying jobs i
mean the oil and gas industry
recruitment has been going for so long
it's a very established market and
therefore
there's a lot of processes in place that
kind of stop you from what i would call
now
doing proper recruitment okay so so
a lot of that first 18 months was
figuring out how to
head ons yeah which don't get me wrong
is an incredible
skill and want to advise anyone who's
starting
recruitment to master very quickly
because you've not got enough time
to head on people when you get good at
the job
yeah because when you get good at the
job you're trying to make clients better
you're trying to find new clients
all the time and you so you've not got
time to be had hunting
yeah for eight hours a day so yeah don't
i
i really enjoyed my first two years but
i was kind of gone yeah how would you
sum it up like how
because obviously it's typically like
the first year or so that can be the
most difficult that was definitely the
most difficult for me but like
obviously enjoyed it like how would you
sum up those first 18 months
um i enjoy i enjoyed it i didn't feel
like
i was um with too many um
like-minded people so in that context
um but no it was it was um
valuable let's say so it didn't
recruitment didn't chew you up and spit
you out and chris was like right okay
i'm not doing recruitment anymore no no
i enjoy it's hard
it's really hard and i enjoy stuff that
stuff that's hard so
um yeah okay so
then join evolution which i know is is
what we're gonna sort of focus on
so join evolution and the sort of first
half of you being the evolution
was just for content so it was uk market
right because for the last
two and a half it's been not the uk and
it was at like similar markets to what
you do now in terms of tech
yeah so i came on board and
i remember interviewing a few companies
when i decided to leave
um my first company and the owner of the
business gareth
who did the problem you must have been
ripe wrecked direct property mate 18
months
enjoyed i know yeah and
i came in i did the interview and i kind
of decided i was going somewhere else
okay um and then gareth did this
i came and turned into evolution for
i think it was like seven o'clock in the
mornings i need to work at half eight
and guys rattled on for about two and a
half hours
um so i was really late so at that point
i definitely had to lead into company
but he gave me this big speed he's a
manchester city fan and i'm like a city
fan
he gave me this massive speech like the
next vincent company
and just bought it but whether he was
going to be the next vincent
yeah yeah yeah the vincent company of
the company
well but i bought it but i thought
i was kind of um kind of i almost felt i
knew everything in recruitment
yeah when i came to evolution and i
didn't know um
didn't know a lot let's talk about that
because i think
that's i think that's i think that's
quite interesting isn't it that like
especially for those that worked at one
particular company for a long time it's
very like you don't know
i think this is what's changing with
this podcast and you have more access to
things but
you can be really insular can't you and
sort of and
be susceptible to yeah this is how our
company does that's how we do
recruitment sort of thing but
what what would you say were the key
things that you quite quite didn't know
or
was not where or didn't learn in the
future
when i came to evolution i got given a
patch that hadn't been worked before
no one had done it before we had no
clients
um i remember during the interview
process they asked me to do a
presentation
i remember saying oh what i'd do is go
and speak around the company and see
which clients
fitting with my patch and they said with
no clients
i was like wow right that's that's
interesting so
anything around bringing on new clients
i haven't got a clue about
and if you're in 360 that is the hardest
bit about the job hardest part
away spending most of your time i also
didn't know about building a patch
um but if you if you've got a patch then
you've got to think of 20 plus ways of
finding people within that patch and was
it just done on geography mate just for
context
yeah it was i did a northwest uh uk
java um contract okay
that was that well that was the chris
bennett patch that you got
well i quickly found out that people
have been nailing this pack for quite a
while
um but yeah that was that was my area
that's
my performance so let's break this down
then so
that first year then or we could talk
about the first two years or whatever
like what what what ended up being your
plan then chris because i do get
messages a lot around
how to break new patches or how to start
growing a new patch and i know
before we started this you said this is
something that you ended up really doing
but like what
what what ended up firstly what ended up
being the plan
if you had one i remember some really
good advice
when i came into this job that my
director at the time told me
and he said basically when
if you're running a shop and you're the
only person at that shop
if you're not working it's closed right
and if you create a patch you have to be
working
ridiculous hours it's very very
difficult unless you've maybe done it
two three four times
before so if it's the first time you've
ever done it then it's very difficult
and needs a lot of time most of that
time
is going to be spent on admin yeah most
of it's going to be spent on admin
which you need to try and do as much as
you can
outside working hours right so that's
kind of that's the first challenge
is that most recruiters aren't willing
to do that
yeah right so that's the level you need
to do it
also you've got to have the unreasonable
and unattainable target of knowing
actually everyone in your patch yes
anyone who is a java contractor in the
northwest
you have to attend to know right
and they're not all on linkedin yeah the
not only database they're not on stack
overflow
they're not on github yeah they're
everywhere
yeah some are just not on any of these
platforms
at all so you've got to attend that and
every single day you come into the
office
you have to trying to find more people
even though you think you might know
enough
so it's a really difficult mindset to
have a goal that you can never achieve
but always try and get to it
i love that but it's a good one to have
though so that was your mindset going
into it they were there was
there that was like the north star of
light so basically i feel
was the internal dialogue each day what
can i do today to take me a step
closer to knowing everyone in my in my
patch
yeah so up until about
a year and a half ago i was always
candid focus
which led me to the clients uh i
probably changed now
but initially it was all always about
trying to get all the candidates in one
place so they knew me they trusted me
i've met them i could offer them value
yeah
one one of the biggest challenges in
recruitment is offering value
on a new patch right when you've done a
few patches you can figure out ways of
doing that um
more easier but um yeah it's difficult
to offer value
and therefore i had to be at every meet
up
yeah me too was that so that was that so
let's just break this down at the
beginning this new patch that you did
right because i know yeah
the nordic's patch was also a new patch
that you built out
yeah yeah so this northwest java
contract
yeah yeah you shared with us what the
goal was a goal that you can never
achieve but it's something that
sort of really you strive for the light
so then you just go and say then you
ended up really focusing on candidates
and have been for a while
so you starting this patch then did you
then just start speaking
how do you just start to speak to java
contractors or try to speak as many java
contracts as possible yeah yeah that was
it i remember
my target was um was to add five java
contractors a day
um and yeah that's the end you're just
gonna keep on adding
and keep on figuring out reasons to
speak with them again
but to do that you've got to add value
yeah
that's the hard part the beginning isn't
it everyone's trying to do this
um so figuring out where to add value
is where the money is in recruitment i
think so if
you're steiner and you patch go to the
neatos salts
how did you how did you come across the
meetups chris like why did you end up
looking at why did they end up being the
meet-ups that ended up being
a good way to do that like how did you
how did you identify that
i believe evolution um
got involved on the agile warrington
meetup
yeah and we hosted our office um
agile warrington yeah well yeah there
was quite a few people actually it's
amazing how many people you get down for
free pizza
so they started doing that and agile is
a part of
anyone in tech that agile is a part of
their patch in some way or another
so i went to the meet up yeah figured
out
um that there's some value here you can
have
face-to-face meetings with people quite
easily like wow
i'm striving to get these every day so
i went to the java meetup in uh
manchester united
how did you get an invite how did you
get an invite i didn't i didn't get an
invite just i just went
and um on your own yeah yeah yeah
and um there was about eight people
there of which
it's like they they weren't bothered
that i was there yeah because i was
speaking that they're kind of their
language
how did you approach it let's just talk
about that how did you approach that
meetup because
i think this is because i think what a
lot of recruiters because
events have been done i think they're
great i don't think they're ever they'll
ever be done it's so important to bring
people together and people love that
community
meeting like-minded people etc but i
think recruiters
i think when they think oh if i tend to
meet up wonder they want me there
like like how do you how do you approach
it in a way where
i guess you're not perceived as a
typical recruiter going around there
just to
me like how did you approach it what was
the mindset well first you've got to
kind of admit you are a recruiter and it
just doesn't
it doesn't matter when people are
ashamed of it yeah if you're if you're
ashamed of being a recruiter
don't be a recruiter end of love yeah
you are a recruiter but
if you start calling yourself something
like a broker
or a consultant yeah that that's what
you are
you're a broker of services yeah and
that's it especially on contracts
uh you're just introducing two people to
another and
to do that you've got to know everything
in your market yeah what's going on
who's hiring
so when you go to these events yeah if
you're going to speak to them about jobs
or asking for cvs
you've done it completely wrong yeah
you've got to be speaking about
why why i used to write down a few
questions that i would ask
uh before i go to the event and get them
in my head so every time i met someone
new
i would ask them and what i'd recommend
is go to the person who's stood on their
own
it's easy to speak because they want to
speak to someone as well any questions
yeah just like just how did you write
down how did you prepare
um i always used to go in with a
question so where where have you come
from today
yeah that's a good one to get things
going and
um why are you here today what are you
looking to get out of today
and then just listen have a conversation
yeah
and then trust me it'll end on
recruitment when you say
i'm a recruiter yeah i'm a broker
yeah because they're interested they're
polite um
and that's it and you know what throw in
give them a few leads tell them who's
hiring yeah tell them clients you don't
work with who's hiring it's not
it's not difficult i add some value to
their day
and do realize that that's just one of
100
200 people you have to do it to get some
business if you start realizing like
that
one is just part of the process and
therefore the outcome
shouldn't really matter yeah no chris i
absolutely love that i think that's such
a
great practical piece of advice online
if you're going to a networking event
100 prepare
i love that so much and have and i think
what's great about that
is you you've got questions up your
sleeve
that just that helps you just be a bit
more confident when you're reaching when
you're
approaching people right and you're
speaking to people for the first time
which is it is hard
it's not easy just to go up to random
strangers and talk to people but
if you know what you're going to ask to
get the conversation going
that's great advice even even if you go
to these events now
um you go to these events and you don't
need to speak to anyone
make sure you blog it incredibly yeah so
if you want to sit down
at the back yeah take some pictures and
write something on linkedin
about what's going on at the events uh
do that because that's a start that's
still better than most recruiters
yeah so if that's where you want to
start to find
um if not get the courage have some
preparation and don't worry about the
outcome if they sell i don't want to
speak to a recruiter
that's fine that's part of our job okay
everyone wants to speak to everyone okay
so five java contractors a day
carried on doing that recognized meetups
was a good opportunity you go to this
one in manchester
how when did you when obviously from
what under i was a permanent creator but
from what i understand
contract um recruitment is the harder
part
even though it's hard in perm but the
harder part is actually getting projects
and clients and
businesses that you can actually place
contractors with um
because there's also there's more
movement on the contract side right in
terms of actual candidates
so how did you then shift this into a
gear of
working with your new client or whatever
what was the time frame of you
having this mindset how long did it take
before you actually started
bringing on clients well when i went to
that first meet up
yeah i realized quite quickly that this
could be much more
much more than it already is so i asked
the woman at the front who was running
the meetup
if she wanted help if she wanted could i
sponsor it could i get involved that way
because then once you've got that then
you've got another reason to speak to
people
yeah so you could get no business at all
about from the meetup but now you've got
another conversation to ring
yeah i always say when you start your
patch you um
i used to do two hours in the morning of
conducts and two hours in the evenings
yeah
outside working i was so like seven till
nine and then
five onwards yeah that was kind of my
core time
and if you're speaking all this i went
to this meet up
and we're discussing this what are your
thoughts or have you heard about this
meetup
or last time when they were talking
about this and they wanted to speak on
this
who do you know you're having miles
better conversations then
do you want a job or are you and this is
with candidates
yeah this is with candice now where that
where that i suppose
when i started uh billing uh
how long did it take you mate how long
did it take you to for you to make
yourself i got
a first first deal
in after three months yeah
and then after that it two minutes to
month number seven on the second deal
but
month from the seventh i got five deals
um and had an incredible month to be
honest on contact that just sets you up
i remember being on the um car park of
cheshire oaks
yeah looking at my my pair
thinking wow i've just got my overdrive
uh and it was like quite a memorable
moment i thought right
yeah so maybe because and then it's that
confidence isn't it but it was it
from month free so up in someone free
it's all new
you're doing stuff uh constantly new got
my deal
sorted and then after that you think i
have an idea i can do some more
videos and everything that could go
wrong went wrong
and so many learns between let's say
month three to month seven
i remember sat um desk over that's when
you can't see it but um about half eight
to nine
just thinking i can't get anything i
can't land anything i'm really
struggling and
um i ran my manager at the time and he
was
just saying you're doing the right
things you're doing the right things
keep on going
and i did and thankfully i did um and
yeah yeah so month seven so let's let
let's just talk about that period chris
i know you're just coming back there
just for a sec
and then we'll segue into how you then
built on this
because there'll be a lot of if you
think about now the the world that
we live in there'll be a lot of
recruiters that will be that will
probably going through that
or have been going over the last three
four months or i may not have made a
deal
during the whole kobe period so like
when you was going like you said
you made that first deal you're like
right i can do this now recruitment
completed it
not to do it and then you don't do any
more deals until month seven
you just said exposure manager and they
told you keep doing what you're doing
but like how did you push yourself
through that like how did you actually
get through that because that's tough
that's not easy how did you deal with
blanking
thankfully i've always i've always
worked harder when i'm not doing well
yes that's one thing that i was
fortunate to always have
um but it's you've got to rely on the
people around you
yeah if you are going through
i suppose it's different to look at this
initial stage of doing a 360 patch and
compare it with
what's going on at the moment yeah but i
suppose that there are some
similarities but when you're starting
off a patch
and you maybe you've never done it
before then you've got to trust the
people around you
yeah you've got to trust the managers
brought you on board
yeah that they know what they're talking
about
and everyone uses the phrase like back
to basics
make sure you're doing the basics yeah
if you sat on github all day trying to
find one more java developer you're
doing it wrong
yeah you're doing it really wrong and
therefore you've got to
you've got to trust the basics of the
job so what people around you are doing
make sure you're doing that so that
that's the first
first place to focus but yeah it's
difficult to compare it to
what's going on the moment is right now
my advice
so what everyone's going through now is
if you if you've already done well you
know what works
keep doing that keep doing that and
the timing will come yeah don't expect
to be doing any better than you were
doing before
but just keep doing that um yeah and i
suppose no i love that
so the the advice that i no really i
think that's great advice chris so
basically
what you're saying is if you're going if
you you're going through a real tough
patch
if you're early on or you're doing the
new patch or whatever and and yeah you
might blank for the last three months
two months however long
i guess what you're saying there and i
really had to do this as well with the
people around me because i've got the
same advice he should keep doing what
you're doing you're putting a lot of
activity work ethic blah blah blah
it's basically trust what people are
telling you around you trust the process
because when you're in trouble is when
you get up in your own head of doubt
yourself
you're like what am i doing blah blah
blah so what you're saying is try and
fill that out
by really trusting what people say
around you basically when you're going
through those difficult periods if
they're generally saying chris
you're doing the right things it'll pay
off yeah trust the process
of the basics of the job yeah keep doing
that
but you've also got to kind of in fact
you've also got to take some
accountability
and you've also got to realize that if
you want to get
99 people end up in good place in life
have gone through all of these
exact same things in one way or another
yeah
so just appreciate that it's just part
of the process
even if you end up after three months
not billing
the sack yeah but you really love
recruitment
that's not the end of it it's just part
of your process yeah
so that's so just focus understand that
this happens
understand that you're accountable for
it and therefore you have to change
but just make sure you do the basics
along the way
love that so let's let's fast forward
then
how did you end up finishing in the
first and year one then of sort of
trying to
make something out of this patch did
your first deal in three months in
five deals come month seven what how did
you end up finishing
year one in terms of your contract but
roughly or like how did it plan itself
out
i think i think first year yeah i ended
up
bringing in about 100 grand something
like that
yeah um yeah i think i think i was on
about
fluctuating anywhere between about a 2
000 to about 4
000 weekly book value okay
how so obviously worked really hard to
get to that point
you must how did you feel going into
year two of this patch then was you're
quite excited by it did you see what oh
yeah
yeah so how so obviously basically what
you've done in that year one is well
your absolute socks off to give yourself
a foundation that hopefully you can take
to the next level right
going into year two so what what was
what was the plan going into the year
two and by the time you then switch to
nordics but like
how did you plan on growing this patch
so it's double what it is or whatever
the goal was like what was the plan to
expand it
and grow it
[Music]
i've always i've always done the
business plans yeah and first i thought
it was like a bit of like
just a management tool to be honest um
but i've always done business at the
start of the year
and if you if you said you could ask
this question i could have checked my
business plan
but i i reviewed my business plans
probably
i probably did it about a month two
months ago
and like i'm not joking like 70 80
percent
of it this country 78
yeah so what i would say is most likely
i would have wrote and written down the
business plan
yeah and committed to it but
i suppose year two i was obsessed
i was i was going to like at least one
meet up a week after work
one meet up yeah um probably
four five four five a month
i was in a position where i was working
so
hard that allowed me to
sometimes do stuff outside patch because
people above me allowed me to do it
because i would go above and beyond to
do it
so i suppose i was in a good place in
the company that i had
already understood i'd love this job and
i was okay
so they gave me the flexibility to kind
of chase other stuff
yeah if need be if you're always relying
on
sticking to your current patch there are
limitations with that
um so yeah i suppose
i just put myself in a decent position
to
explore other stuff okay so why don't we
then before we go into the nordics
piece that i'm really keen to get into
why don't we just give people context so
like maybe we can talk about i don't
know where you
where your book was or where you were
sort of billings wise before you
transferred over
transferred over to nordics and then
i'll
then i don't know what i want you to do
is then just think about what
looking back what you think were some of
the key contributors that helped you
um achieve that right which is what i'm
keen to do so i guess
end of year two maybe we could just do
that or by the time we left
where was you actually said 100k first
year where where was you at
book wise second year
it was about it's quite difficult to man
there's been a bit of a roller coaster
but
it's right mate just roughly i'm not
going to hey
the key milestones was that i left
doing uk recruitment with just over a
10k
book okay cool so let's just let's just
use that as the guidance right
left by the time you got to around 10k
um book right
which is which is great and considerable
growth compared to where it was year one
so let's just think about that for a
second chris and the reason why i'm
digging into this is because
a real common question i get and i'm
sure you've had this now from
your colleagues is that i always get
questions and people ask me
i've hit this glass ceiling i i feel
like i can't
earn any more or i've reached this
billing target and i've always ended up
trying to
exceed it but i've always end up hitting
the 200k mark or whatever it may be
right so
i guess what i'm just interested to find
out from you is what you think were some
of the sort of
core contributors that maybe you did
differently or the things that you
really double down on that you think
really helped you get to that 10k
milestone it's getting yourself
in a position with the company that
you're working on
that they trust where you're going
so i remember doing like three scala
deals in
dublin um which was oh my god that's
that's definitely out of the patch mate
yeah yeah it's out of the patch but no
one else had it
and um the company kind of trusted me to
deliver on it
so what i would say is to get
to a 10k book i had to do work outside
my patch but also be incredible on my
patch
so the way i did it and
it's maybe not helpful to a lot of
people this but it's just work
ridiculously hard yeah that's it it's
there's no
if you're looking for a magic wand then
you're looking at
eight nine ten years of recruitment
knowledge that you can put together and
use um use that but i didn't have that
had
well two years of resourcing at one
company
and one and a bit years of
360. that was it so i had to conv
i had to what i would say is be
incredible your patch also you're gonna
be incredible the peripheries of that
patch
because that's where your
entrepreneurial spirit comes in and kind
of your inner entrepreneur
is that if you see something else that
you have a good feeling that it's worth
pursuing
you've got to be you've got to follow it
sometimes um
and you've got to be in a position in
the company that they trust you to
follow it
yeah if you're if you're a company that
kind of doesn't
allow you to do that there is
some limitations with that really um
that if you can just do stuff within
your patch
i don't think i've seen um and i've only
worked at two companies but i don't
i don't see i've seen a 10k book with
people just doing the patch
yeah okay you still i got i'll go now
that's interesting but i think the
interesting
which is a really important point you
make chris is about this
we're talking about billings and all
these things but actually there's
there's a real value in building trust
from the people around you i i couldn't
agree with that more
yeah i think that and that's because i'm
assuming now when we talk about
nordics that was part of it i'm assuming
that like how did you then
i'm assuming that you saw an opportunity
or and then when do you know what i'm in
so
let's talk about for the last two and a
half years then so what have you
how did this come about why did you end
up focusing on another patch
that you've never done before or the
business has never done before
and yeah the nordic tech market how did
how did this come about
so when i when i finished the java
northwest patch
yeah and i say i finished i just moved
on yeah someone else came in
i kind of i gave them a patch and
then i started doing scarlet and we
started doing london as a company
and someone else has started that patch
contract
and said chris can you help this person
and we're going to attack it as a team
so i did it and everything i was doing
in the northwest
just wasn't working because it was
nailed down by
some companies who were just too good at
it yeah yeah
and you're gonna kind of hold your hands
up it's like you find a losing battle
how long did you give it
say eight nine eight nine months yeah
now
if anyone starting out on the 360 pack
you've got to give it longer than that
but i'd already done
one patch i kind of i already knew
if this was going somewhere no i didn't
really change patches as such but when i
was talking about being really good on
the periphery of patch
all the leads i was pulling from the
scala developers
most of them were in europe um so i was
like
fancy like london's locked down
yeah they're just massive companies that
can't break into they've already got
either psl's that i don't want to work
on
or they've already got people who
specialize in that as a company
i can't offer either of those so let's
go and chase some of these leads in
europe
and i was doing it a bit on and off um
and it was nothing really was coming of
it
and then i spoke to um spoke to one of
the directors of the company
and told him like what i was doing he
was like you're only like chasing it for
let's say an hour of the day um so he
said
do it for two weeks purely yeah chase
all those leads
intensely for two weeks and stop them
everything else
focus so i did that next thing you know
i got
some i had a client in berlin i declined
amsterdam accountants.com
and fortunate enough for me the
clients.com
was just about to like just go mental in
terms of recruitment
so and you don't focus on that
and next thing i know i've got a team of
six people
doing stockholm i love that again coming
back to the
entrepreneurial spirit following
opportunities building that truck so i
love that i think
everything that you worked your absolute
socks off leading up to that point
created your own luck to get that i do
you know what i mean i really believe
that everything that you put in there
internally and externally in terms of
what you've been doing
gave you that opportunity so let's talk
let's talk about this then and focus on
this so from that point then chris just
for context how long have you been
building that out then so you mentioned
their team of uh yeah a small team but
from that point is it what a two year
was it two years a year and a half how
long has it been do you think
uh building the team so it start when i
when i started pulling the um
clients in stockholm and i started
focusing on that
um i was in a fortunate position like i
said i built enough terminal trust
that i had the resources um
to help me get my book so i ended up
getting my book at one point to 17.5
weekly book value at one point which was
ridiculous so the best times i've ever
had
and but then it got to a point where
it wasn't i needed to think bigger
as an individual and i needed to change
into
into a manager and i've had several
conversations
with my director about where i wanted to
go in my career
and if i was just gonna kind of rinse a
couple of clients
and just have people working as
resources
there's only a certain level you get to
in your career
um so i had to had to look at management
um and then since then that's where all
the challenges have been
you know management in people and i love
it
okay so let's break this down what i'm
keen to do chris but i'm keen to
so it's another real common question i
get from recruiters that go for that
journey so i'm keen to
dig into those challenges of management
how you've got better at it what you've
learned and we'll do that but before i
do
i just have to ask one or two questions
around
business development growing this book
getting clients right so
focusing on stockholm nordics
let's just go real practical here chris
because it's one of the most common
things i always get asked about
what was your best what were your best
methods
best ways of getting new clients
to build up this book in a completely
new patch what was the most effective
way for you
it's the exact same as any patch get to
know all the candidates
give them some value and ask for value
back
yeah as simple as yeah give them give
them
what's going on in the market give them
who's hiring that you don't work with
um and then honestly ask them can you
introduce me
and that that worked yeah
yeah leveraging so you went
really focus on candidates and then
gave value do do what you do best get to
know them blah blah blah
and then yeah ask for something in
return and get leads that way
absolutely it's leveraging those
relationships
i suppose when you're building these
banks of calendars
within your patch you know the companies
that work for as a contractor
and therefore you are constantly
approaching them if i'm
if we as a team myself spoke
speaking to candidates two hours in the
morning
and candidates two hours in the evening
you've got technically a full day
of approaching these clients approaching
them
selling in canada so for the whole for
the whole rest of the day chris sorry to
button you're doing what you'd
say is it business to be there
yeah it's bd unless you've got any
internal meetings or anything like that
but it's beating
um that was when i was on my own i
suppose
um managing a team you've got kind of
other duties
yeah yeah of course okay why do you why
do you think then chris because you hear
this a lot don't you hear this in
recruitment that
all our business has done free referrals
right you always hear that don't you
that you hear like yeah look
it's all referrals blah blah blah and
obviously a really successful way that's
worked for you is
yeah leveraging your relationships and
candidates to get your introduction and
get you into
to clients like why do you think that's
been effective
we've been we've chosen our apaches
carefully
every time we've started a new patch
it's based on patch that either i've
done or
it's on the edge of one of our patches
yeah so
javascaler react java
all close to link patches so
yeah it's it's words because we've
always done something that's close to
what someone else is doing
so i'm speaking as a manager now really
and
yeah we've always always tried to do
patches that are very very
um close to linked to each other and i
suppose
but during the day of doing bd
if you've picked your patches well and
you know the best candidates
and you're genuinely just selling in i
mean in stockholm we don't do cold
calling
we don't do it at all no i've never
really done cold calling at all
to be honest in my whole career um i've
done it sometimes
only if i'm really really desperate um i
think
well word emails clear emails clear in
mails
um focusing
one thing i'm always playing with my
team is that when we get these
opportunities when we've created
something from emails
or emails is having really clear
defined um outcomes of that meeting
going over-prepared yeah
and that that's that's where you get
your results because if you just go in
and try and wing these meetings you've
missed
such a big opportunity yeah so hard to
come around
so yeah i suppose okay all right you
might have just been talking about there
but what
okay so just quickly just real practical
here chris now this will seem the second
nature to you but i think
it'll be something that people might
want me to ask or whatever but like
are we literally are we literally asking
candidates here and what you're getting
that seems to be effective is
hey chris look could you introduce me to
x
and are you then literally getting an
email are they literally then emailing
you going hey
like
generally got jobs to talk about but if
you've got a patch
right now and you aren't video calling
that's
that patch yeah and setting up constant
video calls
then you're doing it wrong you missed an
opportunity because you and me i'll have
the conversation now on the video
call and you introduce yourself
they introduce themselves they know what
they're on the call for
uh you open honest about what you want
to get out the call
um you do this enough and remember
if you're adding value to them they're
gonna give some value back
at some point so asking them can you
introduce me to your manager
who's who's hiring within the company
i've been working with this person
before if you're doing that face to face
and you're confident about it
then you can new business
isn't too difficult um but you've got to
be able to add value to people
that that's the key i suppose if you can
add value to candice then
they'll lead you in the right direction
um
yeah and then the question i wanted to
ask chris before we talk about
management
where where do you see recruiters go
where do you commonly see recruiters go
wrong with bd then because you spoke
about you
don't want to do it yeah
so you just said under preparing for
like you work so hard to get that
opportunity to see them on a video call
meet them
speak to them over prepare
for those meetings but where else do you
see sort of recruiters go wrong
you've got to be passionate about
creating your own little business
right and so you've got to
it means a lot when you get those
meetings it means a lot
getting that client so you've got to
kind of have some like emotion
tied to this so i just i think where a
lot of recruiters go wrong
is that they're here just just to
have a job get on with it if they can
spec a candidate out and someone bites
brilliant
if not it's not the end of the world
um that's the difference between
kind of people who are going to get
mediocre results which are still really
good results in life
but all compared to those people who get
incredible results
is because they've got kind of
incredible um
outcomes that they want to achieve yeah
and they're constant about that
so yeah i think i think just being
passionate about what you do loving the
job
and wanting to get what are quite bold
outcomes but
very achievable that's interesting no
that's interesting so you
actually brought it down to yeah really
understanding why you're doing what
you're doing having a real hunger and
passion for it which
is gonna yeah help you get through okay
i love that
um management then chris how long so how
long then
have you been managing
i'd say two and a half years i think
okay yeah yeah what has been your
biggest challenges then because this
comes up all the time
you hear all the time billing managers
most difficult role in recruitment
like what have been the biggest
challenges for you then chris
micro management
to give us a bit more change so then you
ended up
micromanaging people yeah so i
came out of um came out of doing 360
and i've done a few patches successfully
um i thought i knew the way of doing
recruitment
yeah and and i wanted to make people
successful
um and therefore i was like
i can show you what i've done this is
the thing i've done so let's just go
with this
right so that's what we went with
and uh i would have yeah yeah just like
this is the way we're doing it
everyone just follow me and it kind of
worked
don't mean then especially when we came
into uh
especially when we came into lockdown
four or five months ago
you realize that you can't do that
there's so much it's
you've got to trust people a lot more
than i was doing
um so that that was that was my biggest
challenge initially
um yeah
questions around that no no no it's a
really common one chris right because
what you're basically saying there is
that
what you did as a manager is you put you
basically
expected them to do things that you do
yeah which there's no other crit there's
no other chris bennett there's no other
they're like you can't you can't do that
this always comes out of this is that
one of the common things is the
yeah a billing manager or whatever will
go look this is how i've done it this is
how i've created success for
so this is how i expect you to do it but
actually
you can do that and yeah it might work
for you but
there might be a point if that's locked
down if that's different things where
there's limitations on that and you have
like what have you had to work out then
how people tick
what works better for other people is
that what you've had to be more open
minded
yeah i've learned quite quite a lot over
the
last four months to be honest um i just
think where i went massively wrong
was um
initially start with trust and proper
trust
not like yeah you hired them in your
team absolutely trust me like yeah yeah
but make sure they are accountable
right make sure they're counseled
because if if you're always doing your
system your way
and micromanaging in your own way then
they've always got
that to fall back on the fact that
yeah you told me to do this yeah this
how you want me to do it
and therefore it's not theirs yeah
losing losing the passion
that i've said is is needed in this
so once you introduce accountability
and trust then so much better things
start to happen
and people start doing their own way and
you start as a manager learning about
different ways
so that's the biggest learning i could
ever have in terms of
yeah just yeah i know i love that that's
awesome
learn to empower them to do it their own
way
take accountability for what they're
doing and i guess
and yeah i really trust them and then i
guess within that chris it's like
you just being really happy and
comfortable that there's some like core
principles that you'll agree as a team
that
you have a non-negotiables but and then
like how chris
like do you know what i mean i feel like
that's yeah
[Music]
so right now my team
uh we've got a few people on furlough
but um we've got a team that's three of
us
and we only have we have three meetings
a week
catch-ups yeah so half 12 every um
monday wednesday friday and that is just
to check in without everyone see
everyone doing
um we have the option to do it on
choosing thursday but you don't have to
don't have to do it and then we have
because right now it's the client side
you need to focus on
yes the client side needs to work it's
the relationship management
it's improving those relationships stay
in touch with people
and because as a team we realize that's
the most important thing
then we have a meeting every other one a
meeting actually every week
one hour meeting on a friday to discuss
where we're up to with that
yeah so we're climbing clear defined
goals as a team of what we need to be
doing
and that's where we discuss we finish
early on friday finish it free
and then for that meeting it's
discussing where we're up to with that
what results have you got from that week
and that is where we
hold each other accountable and one
thing
i had to instill that i never did before
is that you have to get the rest of the
team
to hold each other accountable that's
included in my team to me
that's including uh one of the team to
the other other part of the team
so everyone is holding each other
accountable and i suppose
if they can't handle that then
that's where trust breaks down doesn't
it and that's what you kind of have to
that's what that's that's the issue
that's how a lot of micromanagers
created as well
no i really like that that's really
interesting i i really like that
um okay chris so what i would definitely
keen just to ask you to get your
thoughts on
how have you gone about the nordics
market completely different country
different culture
how have you gone about unders how did
you go about understanding that because
i feel like
there'll be a lot of recruiters right
now or have been due to this or will be
thinking it in hindsight like that they
do need to diversify they shouldn't be
like you said about the patch and things
like that you should
god we made a mistake and being north
west java blah blah blah
and i think a great way and i'm sure
you've noticed that there's been more
and more competition over the last two
or so years of uk recruiters
recruiting in the nordics and other
countries and in the eu
and i think a big part of that is
enabling recruitment businesses and
recruiters to
have a diverse way of being able to
build their business right
so i think one thing that always holds
people back or what people most curious
about
is i'm in warrington i'm in manchester
and i'm placing people in
the nordics right like how do people
actually
how receptable are people to that and
how did you go about understanding the
nuances
of this culture well by default
if you're a british recruiter you come
with a tag
yeah exactly or
kind of wear that on your sleeve really
don't be a [ __ ] like i said before don't
be ashamed
you are who you are yeah don't start
pretending you're based in stockholm
don't change
linkedin saying i'm based in stockholm
or based in berlin or wherever you're
doing that
you are who you are i don't know who you
are i love that and
in stockholm in the nardis transparency
is key
so if you think about bringing any of
your dodgy tactics
or co-by recruiting it's gonna fail
how did you work out why how did you
work that out how did you work out
transparency did you not
i don't know oh because it gets brought
up three times me trying to
transparent yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you have to be completely transparent
so your margins what you earn
yeah that is it's public information you
pick that up on from the meeting
straight away yeah
yeah and so if you if you believe you're
charging a high margin you better have a
reason why you're doing it
um could be a complete legitimate reason
yeah it's a niche for all if it's
difficult to fill
then yeah be honest about it but
you might have to give someone a bit
away because you are gonna be
transparent so
that that was one of the difficult
things at start because
in uk recruitment that's not really a
conversation that comes up as much
uh but in the nordics it comes up from
both the candidate side of how much you
charge
and and the client side of how much is
the difference
so that was something that we quickly
had to
get over um apart from that
if you if you are going to kind of
approach uh
doing another country stick with what
you know yeah
if it's if you know java do java in the
other country i hope if you know
contracts
do contracts you i've had some
incredible support around me
um of my director um
helping me with the legal side of what
we're doing
uh so make sure you've got people who
are looking at it
yeah prepare to use their time to do
that
because it is different yeah there are
different contracts
there's different ways of doing things
if you're doing it in germany it's some
of the hardest recruitment you'll ever
do with the most admin
yeah so if you've not got a really good
team behind you to help you
then you're going to struggle um but
yeah yeah it's
it's a massive team effort even the
owners getting involved
the owner of my company's been out a few
client meetings with me
um be prepared to get out there when you
can
um yeah just
you know just be realistic as well yeah
it's it's gonna take a while how long
did you give this like how long
what are you thinking like i had my book
still running
yeah so how what i would say is that
i've always when you when you've got a
good book
and you've just done some deals and
you're above your target
that next month is the time the month to
think about other stuff
yeah yeah it's the thing is that think
about the edges of
uh your kind of market the periphery
yeah what's going on there yeah is there
anything else you can be doing that's
the one to think about it's not the most
kind of just i
think what
next month is the kind of proactive work
starts again
like that so before we finish chris what
i was just keen to get your thoughts on
clearly someone that likes new business
winning clients
built building out new patches like over
the last
obviously a couple of months how have
you as i said to you before i had loads
of messages around always have a message
around this development
but even more so around how
people been approaching over the last
couple of months what changes they've
made and all these things
like how how have you sort of tailored
or changed your approach over the last
couple of months considering what's been
going on on
the business development side i've
become best friends on my marketing team
yeah yes um a lot of the stuff
i do now is centered around
marketing really yeah so if you're five
six seven years into recruitment
thinking you know
about recruitment and know everything
about what's going on recruitment
then one thing i'd suggest doing is go
and learn about marketing
and go and learn about automation and go
and learn about data
and that's been my focus for the last
four months
um about being more of an all-rounded
recruiter so marketing has massively
helped
myself and the company to redirect our
focus
on on different
um goals during what we've been doing so
like i said we've been focusing a lot on
improving our relationships creating new
relationships
and if you've got a really good
supportive marketing team
it's much easier way to do it um
so that's that's my advice if you've got
a marketing
team wouldn't hear their thoughts on
what you're doing so
just quickly because i know we've spoken
about this if you don't mind sharing so
like what's helped you
stay in touch business development is
that you've been calling up people in
the nordic space and
have you been have you been putting
people together or have you like have
you been basically
doing we've been doing articles
yeah yeah so again coming back to your
earlier point around having a reason to
call people
that's what's really helped you during
this period then having a reason it's
like hey
look i'd love to jump on the video we're
doing a series of articles at the moment
to talk about how you're getting on with
things what do you think's going to
change and all these things basically
yeah yeah so we've been doing doing our
schools on
stuff that's kind of relevant to our
patches
relevant to our customers we're
targeting like i said we've got
a meeting every week on you write down
all your clients
and the patches within there's plenty of
stuff that
marketing teams and freelance writers
can write on
if you don't get that content so
right now it's very easy to have
conversations about how teams have been
reacting
how's your tech team doing working
remotely discussing stuff like that and
you are building relationships
and you're putting yourself in what we
call
the luck situation that if you're
speaking to these people
once a month month during that and then
they have got a freelance position
everyone's like how are you looking well
no you just thought of a different way
different reasons yeah so have you seen
a return like have you i know there is
more to it it's not just
ourselves it's actually an opportunity
to give value which you've already
spoken about throughout this whole
podcast but have you like how how is
that how has that helped you or impacted
it i either my business plan this year
yeah i think we had like five goals as a
team
and we're hitting four of them just on
the financial part
yeah yeah yeah so so if you if you
judging this year on finances
yeah unless you're doing i don't know
healthtech
and you specialize in i don't know
logistics
of food and you're doing that type of
recruitment there imagine this year's
could be tough for a lot of people
but if you look at your other goals that
you set at the start of the year
that you are in control of yeah
improving relationships
um building up uh your bank that that
unattainable goal that i talked about
before
finding all the job developers in the
northwest two other contractors
there's no reasoning you can't still
have done this in fact it's actually
easy to find people now
doing all that happening work on the
client side and making sure
every client you're trying to approach
you've got all the email addresses
you've got the
telephone numbers you're constantly
sending them information about what's
going on the market
these are all stuff you can control so i
would
i would argue that um the amazing work
kind of my team has done
we are in a miles better position
going into culvert um and would put
ourselves in a brilliant position that
once the market does pick up again and
we're starting to see that in stockholm
um
love that so before we finish chris what
no
knowing what you know now what what
advice would you give to chris elion in
his recruitment career
um focus
don't forget about others about stuff
outside recruitment
interesting yeah yeah so yeah don't give
up everything for it i would say
really because yeah yeah yeah so yeah
just focus make sure
make sure you still see your family make
sure you do you still see your messages
and stuff like that
or your fellow or whoever it is yeah
because it can
there's no reason yeah because like when
when you said that at the beginning it's
like sort of what i went through my head
is like yeah how sustainable is that
no it's not sustainable it's it's
definitely
if you created a patch yeah you've got
to
be committed to that patch for about
nine months of
very hard hard work um
so if you whip someone at a time make
sure they're clear about that make sure
they know
um if you're not prepared to do the
seven eight months
then then just be realistic be honest
with yourself
that's he returns on it um
and i suppose yeah
back in the day i was always work hard
work hard hard
but now i'm like let's focus a bit more
smarter thinking
yeah so i want to be honest i wouldn't
change much
in terms of like because i've actually
yeah yeah i think that's good advice
right it's like look chris
i know you want to work hard i know
you've got the hunger but
that doesn't mean that that come you
have to sacrifice everything yeah it
doesn't mean you have to sacrifice
everything
yeah yeah i love that chris so um last
question then
how how do you see the land lay
after this like what in terms of
recruitment how do you
how do you see things changing over the
next six to 12
months in your opinion what do you think
is going to change or
what's what you're interested or excited
about and in the sort of
short to medium for future i think um
it's exciting to see how recruitment
companies
react to this yeah the clients will
always be the clients
they'll come back yeah they'll start
hiring they'll start wanting to do psls
someone want to get rid of psls
the whole process once someone won't
earn their month free answer
that'll always be the same yeah but the
the change that will happen is how
recruitment companies
internally work with their staff you'd
like to think that your manager
every month is say asking two questions
really
how do you work best and what do we need
from you really
yeah so if yeah if you work best
five days remotely yeah not in the
office
brilliant if us as a team needs to win
for two
then that's gonna be the challenge going
forward how do we make that happen
between us
yeah do we need you one one day a week
some weeks and two days
because the fully remote um
option is i've enjoyed it but can you
grow a team on it
now you might be able to um but you're
gonna have to have an incredible
training team
you're gonna have to have an incredible
training team who knows how to train
people remotely
so people are gonna have to get good at
that so all these challenges um
are coming up but i think it's mainly in
in recruitment
about how do you train people remotely
how do you work remotely
and how do you hold people accountable
while working remotely
but it'd be interesting to see the days
of shirts and ties
maybe they might be going i don't know
don't know no i think that's going to be
one of the most interesting things
everything you're talking about there
it's going to be really interesting how
people adapt what changes what a typical
five-day working week for a recruiter
looks like it's going to be interesting
um look chris love your energy love your
passion
excited to see from afar where your
career goes but um it's been an absolute
pleasure